i mean this hurts to look at you i just
have to tell you guys you're so
lovely and you're so beautifully dressed
and the fact that you're all from like
tallest to smallest i can't handle it
how did you guys get into the cookie
business first we went to go ask her mom
when she approved of the business
then she told us to go sit down with our
dad
and our dad eventually he agreed to do
it and we came up with the name and the
logo and
it went off from there joshua what has
it been like
working with your brothers and starting
a business
well it's been really fun to be able to
work with my brothers my mom and my dad
and another thing that i really love is
that we're inspiring
kids and adults across the world to be
entrepreneurs
i mean that's so wise micah
you guys are going to school and running
a successful business
how are you managing it all well
how we're doing this is we do our
schoolwork first and then we make the
cookies
caleb what are you gonna do with the
money you're making
well actually we created another
business called kentpreneur expo
which is an online platform that allows
kids
newers that advertise and market in
their business
that's really smart i learned
early that marketing and advertising is
very important because it's how
you tell your story and it's a great way
for you to take control
but also make sure it's exactly the way
you see it
isaiah you are all such cool dudes
what would you tell someone who thought
baking was a girl thing
well drew that's an awesome question
let's say in my trip of imagination
you're on a saturday morning
having some coffee probably just
relaxing
and you have your cookies baking in the
oven at 350 degrees
then when they get out you take a bite
and ooey gooey chocolate all over your
mouth
well yeah yeah one of our biggest
supporters was our grandfather
and he would always tell us whatever you
put your mind to
you can always do it i am so excited
to be talking to you guys and i know
that you sent
us some of your yummy cookies okay
what do we have walk me through it
gentlemen
all right so we have the too faced which
is double dark chocolate mixed with
chocolate chip
then we have chocolate chip
snickerdoodle then there's cookies and
cream
papa's white chocolate macadamia nut
that was named after our grandfather
because he
loved macadamia nuts and then
oatmeal hmm
that we picked out for you is you
juice e.t cookie which is means
extra tasty
gentlemen are so handsome and so
talented
um oh my gosh and the drip cookie
there's
pecans toffee and chocolate chip
i i must tell you guys um
these are truly some of the best cookies
i've ever had in my life and i'm not
just saying that
these are perfect their texture is
exactly what you dream
of and there are so many different
flavors from all the different nuts
they're incredible you guys have made an
extraordinary
product and i know that one of your
goals is to sell your cookies
nationwide and i actually um
heard that you would love to sell in a
store
and i reached out um to the owners of
slim and huskies the first black owned
pizza franchise
in the country
we go there all the time their food is
great their successful pizza empire has
stores nationwide
and i would love to welcome in the
wonderful co-owners of slim and huskies
clint ej and derek
[Applause]
what's up man it's great to meet you
guys we wanted to hop on and say
congratulations
on all you guys success you guys are
true leaders
for your communities and your families i
just want to tell you to keep on going
the best is yet to come for you guys
man we just want you guys to know if you
focus uh continue doing what you love
with the people that you love man you
can't go wrong so
much much success to you guys what we're
going to do
is allow you guys to sell your cookies
in our atlanta stores how does that
sound
awesome awesome so what we'll do we'll
work together on a marketing strategy
and we'll figure out how to make it all
work it sounds good
yeah great thank you for having me
we're gonna obviously if we could be so
lucky to have each and every one of you
up on our website at the drewberrymore
show.com shining lights on your
businesses
we love all of you and everything that
you're doing
in your business communities as well as
being really smart businessman
thank you so much but drew
you know what would be good if we did an
exclusive
slim and husky special cookie
i'm so grateful to clint and ej and
derek
for taking you guys on and the
collaboration that you're going to have
in your near future thank you gentlemen
for that opportunity
for these incredible gentlemen the yummy
brothers
[Applause]
all right keep us posted all along the
way
[Music]
you